[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour cette émission spéciale
de dimanche en politique sur france 3
bourgogne ici en direct de la maison de
la chasse et de la nature de
norges-la-ville pour une heure de débats
en direct et en public près d'un mois
après la démission de nicolas hulot du
gouvernement on se questionne ce
dimanche matin en direct chasseurs et
agriculteurs sont ils les nouveaux
écolos dans un instant je vous
présenterai nos invités mais nous serons
pas seuls à nous questionner à débattre
dans cette émission il ya du monde près
de nous témoin militant ils se sentent
eux aussi concernés par ce débat et ils
sont avec vous elle a besoin bonjour oui
bonjour jean christophe bonjour à tous
effectivement ces grands témoins ils
vont pouvoir suivre les échanges
les débats devant un écran alors qui
sont-ils autour de moi il y à des
agriculteurs des chasseurs à des
associations de défense de
l'environnement mais aussi des militants
politiques des acteurs qui n'ont pas
l'habitude d'être réunies dans un même
lieu des acteurs qu'on a voulu
rassembler ici ce matin pour un grand
débat citoyen en direct sur france 3
c'est une première alors on va venir les
voir c'était moins tout au long de
l'émission régulièrement pour les faire
réagir pour leur donner la parole et
jean-christophe ils vont pouvoir à leur
tour interpellés ou questionner les
invités qui sont sur votre plateau merci
elsa on vous retrouve dans un instant
donc pour les premières réactions et
prise de parole autour de vous et puis
vous qui nous regarde et vous en avez
l'habitude vous pouvez bien sûr
commenter cette émission en direct sur
les réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag dit
mme paul bourgogne alors je vous
présente nos invités didier martin
bonjour vous êtes député la république
en marche de côte-d'or merci d'être avec
nous olivier muller bonjour co
secrétaire départemental d'europe
écologie les verts en côte-d'or merci
également d'être là bourhis obama
bonjour bonjour vous représentez la
france insoumise en côte-d'or merci
d'être avec nous pascal sécula bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le président de la
fédération des chasseurs de côte-d'or
double merci d'être là et puis de nous
accueillir ici dans cette maison de la
chasse et de la nature fabrice jeunes un
bonjour vous êtes agriculteur secrétaire
général de la fdsea en côte d'or la
fdsea c'est la version départemental de
la fnsea l'est de l'inde
principaux syndicats d'agriculteurs
merci à tous les cinq d'accepter ce
débat en direct en public avec les
interactions qu'on a évoqué un débat
contradictoire même s'il se veut
bienveillant vous nous accueillir pascal
sécula ici dans une maison qui s'appelle
maison de la chasse et de la nature dans
l'intitulé il y as nature est ce que
c'était aussi important pour vous que le
mot chasse dans cette maison vous avez
créé je le rappelle il ya deux ans c'est
important de le dire c'est une forme de
communication la nature les chasseurs la
connaissent la pratique depuis toujours
mais effectivement on nous connaît que
sous la casquette chasseurs ou chasse
donc la vraie réorientation de la
communication au niveau national de la
chasse 7 par les natures de parler
d'éducation à l'environnement
on a un projet énorme maintenant dans
deuxième phase de construction
c'est de réaliser des travaux pour faire
venir les écoles les enfants dont deux
scolarisés faire découvrir ce qu'est la
nature et le biotope présent au côte
d'or veut dire que très prochainement
ici il y aura une scénographie derrière
nous avec la volonté d'accueillir des
scolaires tout à fait au même au delà de
l'intérieur et surtout à l'extérieur il
y aura plusieurs hectares à aménager des
sentiers pédagogiques
on va pouvoir découvrir la sylviculture
on va pouvoir découvrir des paysages
agricoles agricole on va montrer aux
enfants ce qu'est la côte d'or au niveau
de la flore et pas seulement au niveau
de la faune olivier muller que je vous
ai invité il ya quelques jours à venir
ici à la maison de la chasse et de la
nature vous l'écologiste quand vous
entendez pascal sécula à dire bah oui la
nature on a envie d'éduquer aussi à
l'environnement à la nature des jeunes
scolaires vous dites chapeau allons-y où
vous dites attention bon je suis assez
consterné finalement
et je crois qu'il veut se situe là à
parler de communication et en est
effectivement dans la communication les
chasseurs essaie de redorer un peu leur
blason qui est dans l'opinion publique
plutôt plutôt plutôt ternie donc on est
dans la communication d'ailleurs leur
campagne publicitaire est complètement
chasseurs premier chasseur premiers
écolos de france c'est assez affligeant
parce que le clip le clip qu'on peut
voir concernant cette campagne ne montre
pas un seul fusil on n'a pas une seule
carabine on a on a fait vraiment ce que
c'est pas le tout de la vie des
chasseurs la carabine
c'est quand même essentiellement
l'activité d'achat c'est quand même
essentiellement tuer des animaux
on est quand même dans la chasse il faut
bien la définir c'est tuer des animaux
on peut être pour ou contre mais un clip
qui ne montre pas un seul fusil qui nous
montre pascal activités de la chasse et
c'est quand même bon une belle
communication mais c'est plutôt un clip
de la nef n'est pas aussi parce que vous
avez finalement laissé un peu la place
aujourd'hui l'écologie politique est en
panne on y reviendra sans doute et
finalement il ya d'autres gens qui sont
proches de la nature et qu'ils disent
ben oui mais nous aussi on peut être
écologiste à notre façon certes mais on
peut être écologiste
on n'a pas vraiment laissé la place
c'est simplement on continue le combat
quotidien simplement tout le monde veut
se réclamer de l'économie aujourd'hui
parce que comme c'est une forte attente
du public
c'est ces bourrins la communication
parler des autres langues à presque
fourche et vous avez failli dire
économie au lieu d' écologie c'est
peut-être les deux sont des cultes et
c'est une des difficultés qu'a connues
et patchouli nicolas hulot va du tout
justement alors j'ai une formation
économique à la base donc ça peut
m'arriver tu cherchais dans le sang à
l'économie mais l'écologie et les et
l'économie ne sont pas du tout au
contraire
alors j'ai de redonner la passe la
parole à pascal sécula parce que
évidemment ça fait des fois sourire des
fois ça agace un petit peu les militants
écologistes cette campagne que vous avez
lancée fin août
les chasseurs premiers écolos de france
est-ce que c'est pas un peu exagéré pas
du tout regardez vous même vous m'avez
donné le seul micro qui avant d'ouvert
c'est le hasard
je pouvais pas la rater si on l'a pas
donnée à monsieur qui se sait chanter
plus vous savez vous savez le bleu c'est
aussi écolo il faut s'occuper de la mer
même si elle est un peu plus loin des
cours d'eau en tout cas je suis bien
content d'avoir le vert une chose est
certaine c'est que la communication que
nous avons mis en place depuis le mois
de faillite début septembre
les chasseurs premier écologiste de
france faisait j'irai étape on avait
besoin de faire réagir la population par
rapport à cela
ça fait trop longtemps que nous sommes
sur le terrain
encore une fois un million cent mille
personnes soixante dix mille
associations locales en france de chasse
environ deux par département c'est cinq
fois plus que les clubs de foot en
france
je regrette de vous dire ça france
nature environnement
c'est combien de personnes c'est
peut-être lp/o je crois que c'est trente
six mille adhérents
oui vous avez en 450 associations au
sein de france nature environnement vous
vous pouvez peser donc mais qu'est ce
que vous faites contre la nature qu'est
ce que l'on fait 3 milliards d'euros par
an d'action pour la biodiversité
donc chaque année non subventionnées
financé par les seuls chasseurs en
réhabilitation de sites aménagement des
reconstructions de chemin zones humides
complètement restauré par les chasseurs
ça c'est du concret c'est une étude
qu'il l'a démontré donc 3 milliards
d'euros c'est pas du vent et en plus
c'est financé par les seuls chasseurs
alors on va on va revenir aux autres
choses que vous pouvez faire et en tous
les cas aussi à cette communication vous
lancer mais on va les rejoindre elle a
besoin parce qu'il ya déjà beaucoup de
réactions forcément le débat commence
très fort hills a alors beaucoup de
réactions je sais pas je peux vous dire
qu'ici il ya des sourires on va
justement allez demander à quelqu'un je
m'approche de vous je vous ai vu sourire
je suis désolé c'est tombé sur vous
qu'est-ce que ça évoque ce que vous avez
vous venez d'entendre la effectivement
j'aurais peut-être sortir de l'image
d'epinal la chasse c'est plusieurs
formes et à la chasse à courre il ya la
vénerie sous terre il ya la chasse à la
glu il ya plein de pratique d'ailleurs
piégeage donc il faut arrêter de sortir
de l'image d'epinal du chasseur avec
tout seul avec son petit fusil et son
chien
toulon peut tout à fait comprendre à la
rigueur maintenant la chasse est devenue
une industrie une industrie de cette
façon là qui gère la nature qui fait d
élevage de sangliers qui fait de
l'agrainage
donc là ça devient un pouvoir économique
qui n'a plus rien à voir que chercheur
d'origine domaine que le paysan
d'origine qui a totalement disparu au
bénéfice de l'exploitant agricole
maintenant qui ravage la planète et on
le voit tous les jours et ce qui est un
peu dommage c'est que les chasseurs et
des écologistes pourraient converger en
certaine dans une certaine mesure pour
protéger réellement la biodiversité
vous faites partie vous d'une
association de défense de
l'environnement est-ce qu'on peut être
chasseur écolo d'après vous c'est
possible mais dans une très faible
mesure est tout ce que je vois au
quotidien sur le terrain parce que je
suis également militant écolo
effectivement les amis de la terre est
aussi scientifique spécialité papillon
cambrai sur le terrain on ne veut pas du
tout 7,7 en réalité la nature ne cesse
de se dégrader depuis 50 ans partout en
france partout en europe les aces ont
ravagé le les sols sont bourrés d
d'herbicides les seuls sont appauvris
les zones humides disparaisse totalement
au goût les inondations à répétition
c'est une catastrophe
on ne va absolument pas dans le bon sens
et nicolas hulot l'a bien dit d'ailleurs
en conflit avec stéphane travert il
n'était pas du tout dans la même
convergence par rapport à l'avenir de
l'environnement donc on prend un
traitement des chemins pour le moment
merci beaucoup pour cette réaction en
avance on est déjà sur la partie
agriculture et je vois que l'agriculteur
qui est à côté de moi va avoir envie de
réagir mais peut-être pascal sécula le
monsieur dit il ya différentes formes de
chasse on peut pas dire qu'elle se
valent tout est qu'elles sont toutes
super écolo est ce que c'est vrai ça est
ce que est ce qu'il ya des façons de
chasse et qui sont peut-être plus
respectueuse de l'environnement et de la
nature que d'autres alors il existe de
nombreux modes de chasse fédération des
chasseurs national régional
départemental on défend tous les modes
de chasse pourquoi parce que c'est notre
culture c'est notre histoire
c'est notre façon de vivre sur le
terrain et on n'entend pas seul à faire
dicter par des gens qui vivent à paris
et qui n'ont jamais vu ce que c'est
qu'une chasse en pleine campagne ont
pleine forêt ça c'est les gens viennent
nous parle aujourd'hui c'est la campagne
ils l'ont fait à paris y vivent en
bourgogne je veux répondre déjà ce
monsieur que je ne connais pas et je
respecte totalement dit malgré chose
quelque chose d'erroné la vénerie c'est
très marginal par rapport au reste il
avait l'impression donnée en l'image
d'epinal en disant qu'il ya peu de
chasseurs qui chassent normalement 95%
98% des chasseurs ne pratique pas la
vénerie mais je respecte la vénerie
jeunes à patrick pas
pas moi même mais en tout cas on la
défend on la soutient ce qu'on a proposé
et j'étais j'ai eu la chance d'être
analysé face au président de la
république
lorsqu'on a présenté nous la fameuse
réunion la fameuse réunion
bien évidemment on était attendu sur ce
thème
on était attendu sur ce thème et
notamment les modes de chasse
traditionnelle et on a proposé des
améliorations notamment pour que entre
guillemets toute la chaîne de la chasse
y compris jusqu'à la mise à mort parce
que appelons un chat il y à une mise à
mort à la chasse à rire et dation cela
soit fait dans les meilleures conditions
possibles et qu'on améliore qui est une
charte de qualité signée par tous les
parties prenantes
effectivement pour que certains abus
certaines dérives qui ont pu avoir lieu
n'existe plus demain ça doit faire
partie de l'évolution de la chasse de
demain on en est conscient et donc cette
charte a été clairement présenté au
président de la république et aux
ministères concernés et on va essayer de
l'appliquer oui parce que c'est votre
contrepartie aux avantages que vous a
octroyé emmanuel macron didier martin
député la république en marche pour à
nous en parler puisque et bien il ya une
réduction du prix du permis de chasse il
ya aussi une diversification des espèces
chassables ça fait partie des deux
avancées qu'ont obtenue les chasseurs
dernièrement didier martin la république
en marche emmanuel macron nouveaux amis
des chasseurs oui des chasseurs et des
écologistes
ah parce que moi je vois l'utilité de la
chasse pour réguler une surpopulation
animale qui causent des dégâts dans les
exploitations agricoles qui peut
provoquer des accidents de la route qui
peut contaminer le bétail on est ici en
côte d'or terre d'élevage et terres
forestières
il ya de la tuberculose bovine on sait
qu'il ya des transmissions du gibier aux
bovins et qu'on ait conduit parfois à
battre des troupeaux entiers
donc moi je pense que les chasseurs dans
leur globalité et je suis content d
salué aujourd'hui ils ont un rôle actif
important dans cette régulation de la
vie animale dans les espaces naturels
est ce que c'est ça ce n'est pas ce
petit filet cadeaux d'emmanuel macro
chasseurs puisqu'on peut parler de
cadeau à la diminution par deux du prix
du permis de chasse et la
diversification des espèces chassables
c'est quand même un avantage certain
demandé par les chasseurs depuis
longtemps c'est surtout un dialogue qui
est repris
était abandonné depuis longtemps par les
anciens présidents de la république donc
moi je il ya aussi les espèces protégées
la tourterelle des bois le grand et rats
et c'est donc il ya eu des avancées dans
les deux sens et nicolas hulot qui a
pris une décision à partir d'un rendez
vous mais on sait bien que il y avait
d'autres questions qui étaient posées
par nicolas hulot on y reviendra tout à
l'heure donc moi je j'ajouterai par
rapport à la chasse c'est que c'est
aussi une attractivité des territoires
ruraux qu'il faut mettre dans l'ensemble
des atouts des territoires ruraux parce
qu'aujourd'hui et un déficit par rapport
à la vie en ruralité et il faut prendre
en compte cet aspect chasse parmi
d'autres ça peut être aussi le très haut
débit ça peut être les services publics
de proximité ça peut être des maisons de
santé
c'est la vie en milieu rural qui doit
être prise dans sa globalité
je pense que les agriculteurs les
chasseurs les écologistes ont tous un
rôle à jouer
alors vos opposants politiques ont envie
de réagir on va les faire réagir dans
quelques instants mais d'abord on va
retourner vers elle a besoin parce que
ça réagit aussi beaucoup de votre côté
elsa oui je peux vous dire qu'ici je
vois des sourires je vois même des noms
de la tête je vous ai vus tout allait
alors bonjour je voudrais vous présenter
sophie beaudry vous êtes militant
wimille tente de la france un cynisme je
vous ai vu réagir tout à l'heure quand
monsieur secula a parlé qu'est ce qui
vous a fait réagir c'est d'avoir cette
présentation effectivement un petit peu
bucolique hédoniste de la chasse c'est
vrai que les chasseurs disperse beaucoup
de plomb dans la nature effectivement
j'étais effectivement je me suis un
petit peu renseigné sur le type de
chasse pratiquée on sait aussi qu'ils
utilisent des balles qui dispersent des
tas de petites billes de plomb de plomb
par tous qui peuvent parfois retombé
aussi sur les promeneurs qui peuvent
être des dangers publics donc c'est vrai
que l'on peut dire que il ya certaines
pratiques qui pourraient quand même être
questionné remise en question est-ce
qu'ils ont un rôle à jouer quand même
les chasseurs ont dans nos campagnes
comme le disait didier martin il ya un
instant alors peut-être effectivement en
ayant des pratiques un petit peu plus
cadré et vertueuse
parce qu'effectivement on se rend compte
la majorité des animaux chassés ne sont
pas des animaux sauvages mais des
animaux élevés pour la chasse il ya très
peu effectivement d'animaux d'animaux
véritablement sauvage donc la question
l'argument de la régulation à mon sens
ne tient pas merci beaucoup on va
continuer on va se se tourne et je
cherche je vais poser la question à
chasseurs bonjour bonjour michel michel
vous vous chasser au quotidien qu'est ce
que vous pensez de ce qui vient d'être
dit moi je voudrais réagir sur une
réflexion du présentateur de christ
jean-christophe de dimanche en politique
qui en début d'émission a interpellé les
hommes politiques en disant l'écologie
politique est en panne et je crois que
c'est un constat oqali il faut se rendre
aujourd'hui mais je crois que l'écologie
tout entière la biodiversité la nature
aurait à gagner justement à ce qu'on
abandonne ce cloisonnement de l'écologie
qui est repris de façon politique par
certains partis alors qu'elle est à mon
sens beaucoup plus transversale
l'écologiste à côté de moi ce matin qui
a dit qu'il y avait certainement moyen
de dresser des passerelles
je pense a parfaitement raison c'est une
façon intelligente de voir l'avenir de
se pencher sur la nature en quittant des
partis politiques qui justement font
perdre l'intérêt de la nature elle même
et donc je crois qu'il ya des
passerelles adressé il ya des intérêts à
retrouver entre les agriculteurs les
chasseurs et les écologistes qui
redeviendront tous des personnes
intéressées par la nature que vous avez
une question pour les élus
oui justement mais certainement
à l'attention des trois députés qui sont
présents est ce que il est nécessaire de
se pencher justement sur la réflexion
politique de savoir si il faut pas
dresser un système transversal pour
parler de l'écologie enfin dans sa
globalité
merci beaucoup alors il ya un seul
député mais les autres ne deviendront
peut-être un jour pourquoi pas on leur
souhaite en tous les cas c'est un drôle
de combat en tous les cas on va revenir
évidemment à ces passerelles comprendre
et c'est peut-être d'un mot une réponse
sur la question des balles perdues vous
dites que vous êtes écolo vous protéger
la nature est ce que là ça fait partie
des engagements que vous avez pris avec
avec le gouvernement pour faire
attention à tous ces détails là pascal
sécula vous alors déjà premièrement des
balles perdues on n'aime pas du tout
parce que la chasse est un sport un
loisir très encadrée il ya de la
formation systématiquement qui s'est
réalisé sur ce site et vous avez des
textes réglementaires avec des vrais
contrôles et de la vraie sécurité
aujourd'hui la chasse à progresser dans
ce domaine là il y encore des
d'accidents chaque année un accident
cian trop je peux vous assurer que par
rapport aux actions de chasse qui se
sont multipliés compte tenu de
l'augmentation des populations de
sangliers dont du nombre de tirs de
coups de carabine par an les accidents
de chasse ont diminué fois deux fois
trois fois quatre donc on est très
encadrée encore une fois on peut pas
dire qu'il ya des balles perdues de
lâcher dans la nature c'est complètement
fou alors j'aimerais entendre olivier
muller sur la question de l'écologie
transversale c'est à dire finalement
c'est pas votre propriété à vous par
exemple europe ecologie les verts et
tout le monde pourrait contribuer est-ce
que ce message qu'on entend aujourd'hui
dans ce débat citoyen finalement où
chacun essaie de faire un pas vers
l'autre vous pouvez l'entendre il en bas
c'est pas que notre fonds de commerce
bien sûr je veux juste revenir sur les
balles perdues
il ya encore une vingtaine de morts par
an en moyenne et ça n'a pas baissé
contrairement à ce que dit monsieur
leterme ballon perdu était mal employé
par le regard du basset des balles
perdues ou c'est d'autres accidents ses
1800 street on a trahi notre dos il se
sait qu avant de venir c'était 10 et 18
ans en 2017
c'est faux vous allez vous avez ces dix
dernières années
les accidents de chasse ont été divisés
par deux vous reprenez bien sûr si vous
reprenez 18 à 20 effectivement
malheureusement il ya deux morts des car
je vous le concède simplement regarder
l'évolution sur dix ans il y a six fois
plus de coups de carabine est ce que je
vous ai dit qu'il n'y avait il ya dix
ans du fait de l'augmentation des
sangliers ça tout le monde est d'accord
là dessus donc ça génère x fois plus de
coups de carabine et vous avez deux fois
moins d'accidents mortels fait deux fois
de trop c'est dix fois trop cette fois
là vous n'êtes pas d'accord je sais pas
c'est roy revenait mais cet aspect
sécuritaire est quand même une
inquiétude justement des citoyens enfin
il ya plusieurs usagers de la forêt on
en parlera peut-être ça ça donne quand
même un sentiment d'insécurité
même si effectivement vous allez me dire
il ya moins de décès à la chasse que sur
la roue l'ontario soit là aussi où est
la route mais ça n'empêche que c'est
quand même déjà 20 morts de trop et
c'est avec une arme sur l'écologie le
fait que tout le monde peut s'en saisir
alors l'écologie politique on y
reparlera peut-être tout à l'heure mais
sur ces mains tendues vous avez entendu
ce chasseur qui étayent un instant avec
elle a besoin il dit on peut tous faire
un pas on peut tous occupés
d'environnement et on n'est pas que des
vilains méchants est ce que ça vous
l'entendez tout à fait je l'entends très
bien et on doit tous travailler ensemble
pour l'écologie ça y'a aucun doute alors
c'est pas sûr justement sur cet aspect
csars démissionné de son poste de
ministre quand on est en face ces
chasseurs
si on veut travailler ensemble avec
l'échéance on en reparlera après je
pense va dire oui voilà on va en parler
après effectivement c'est pas uniquement
l'aspect chasse qu'il a fait
démissionner comportant les autres
dossiers on va dire que c'était un petit
peu la goutte d'eau mais juste pour
revenir sur l'écologie politique on veut
on veut effectivement travailler avec
tous les acteurs c'est indispensable
vous avez dit vous êtes nombreux en
campagne à travailler on héros vous
inquiétez pas on est aussi très nombreux
à travailler sur ces dossiers là
simplement ski
c'est pas sur l'aspect finalement pour
aux contres comme un débat de corridas
qu'on va s'en sortir je pense parce que
ça c'est un débat passionnel et on va
pas s'en sortir sur le territoire en
parlant de ça il faut parler de
biodiversité et je pense que c'est aussi
ce que voulait faire finalement voulait
nous dire que vous protéger la
biodiversité vous essayer de protéger
certaines espèces espèces bon c'est pour
pouvoir mieux les chasser on est
d'accord mais vous essayer de protéger
la biodiversité est on est on est là sur
le même terrain j'espère qu'on partage
le même constat
aujourd'hui et on n'a pas entendu
beaucoup la fnsea berne entendra on va
on va lui donner il faut effectivement
protéger cette biodiversité et les
chasseurs ne sont pas responsables à
100% de la disparition de la
biodiversité l'agriculture a une grande
part dans cette responsabilité je vais
donner apparent laboris aubin pour la
france a soumis ce même s'il ya une de
vos collègues de la france a soumis ce
qui a parlé il ya un instant à côté
d'elle a besoin sur cette question de la
transversalité de l'écologie qui
n'appartient pas à quelqu'un en
particulier d'ailleurs jean-luc
mélenchon il s'est découvert écolo sur
le tard il l'a reconnu lui-même il ya
quelques années
quel est votre point de vue bah tout à
fait moi je suis pas forcément d'accord
en disant qu' il s' est un fake de
l'écologie politique moi je trouve qu'au
contraire en ce moment les citoyens
s'approprient vraiment cette question
nous à la france insoumise on a défendu
des positions écologique mordicus dès le
début de la campagne s'était même au
coeur de notre projet social économique
pour la création d'emplois et c'est donc
moi je suis pas vraiment d'accord avec
ce constat et ensuite vous allez revenir
sur ce qu'a dit monsieur martin
notamment concernant la régulation de la
chasse est vraiment l'argument qu'on ne
sort à chaque fois sachant qu'on sait
qui en fait il y a que 5 % des animaux
sauvages qui sont chassés la plupart des
animaux en fait ces animaux qu'on élève
pour cette pratique là autre chose vous
avait argumenté de créer de
l'attractivité autour de la chasse moi
je pense que la france a quand même
d'autres arguments à faire valoir pour
pouvoir attirer des touristes c'est pas
la gastronomie le vin ou que sais-je que
de deux heures plus tôt par exemple que
de massacrer des animaux et l'autre
point aussi
monsieur martin nous a dit que kid et
que l'offre la république en marche et
et écologistes quand vous regardez
notamment les différents votes qui ont
lu à l'assemblée nationale on a quelques
raisons d'en douter notamment par non
pas sur le bien être animal où vous avez
laissé autorisé la castration des
porcelets à vif où vous avez autorisé le
fait de broyer des poussins vivant où
vous avez refusé qu'on mette des calmes
des caméras dans les différents endroits
d'élevage de bovins etc etc
donc moi je si ça ne dérange pas la
république en marche que l'un civile se
déguisant policiers ne vous déguiser pas
non plus en écologistes parce qu'on sait
tous les tout le monde voit bien que le
réel a lieu et que vous n'êtes pas
écologique alors didier martin je vous
invite à répondent pas sur le glyphosate
parce qu'on va y venir juste après mais
sur les autres sujets merci pour le
déguisement
chacun a un chien chacun a ses postures
politiques non il ya une vraie prise de
conscience des enjeux de l'écologie dans
notre société
simplement la république en marche elle
connaît à la fois l'activité économique
le lapsus de collègues elle connaît
aussi l'activité de l'agriculture et
elle veut emmener tout le monde vers le
mieux et par conséquent la loi est là
pour prescrire pour interdire et puis il
ya le travail qui est fait en amont avec
les professionnels avec la société pour
que tous ensemble on aille vers
effectivement non pas la suppression de
la chasse comme vous avez ses positions
ah ben non c'est vous qui m'ont enfermé
dans ce quelque chose que je sente pas
du tout je conçois qu'on puisse vraiment
factions pour au continent vous avez
simplement des 90% des animaux étaient
massacrés et je crois que c'est une
vision un peu caricaturaux et vous est
ce que vous n'avez pas envie de vous
réconcilier avec le monde rural la
république en marche parce que dira
emmanuel macron et le président des
villes des métropoles etc
est-ce que c'était pas une façon aussi
de récupérer un certain électorat
pourquoi pas le dire quand on parle de
très haut débit quand on parle de maison
de santé en milieu rural quand on parle
de mobilité
quand on parle de service public c'est
bien
les territoires ruraux le monde rural
qui est ciblé parce qu'il ya aujourd'hui
un déséquilibre entre le monde des
villes et le monde des campagnes et
quand je parle de la chasse oui je
maintiens c'est une activité
traditionnelle française qu'il faut
prendre en compte et j'entends ce qui a
été dit par le président secula il ya
des progrès très fort sur la
biodiversité c'est lui qui a utilisé le
mot en premier il ya des soucis
environnementaux importants et donc moi
je crois qu'il faut emmener tout le
monde vers le progrès et pas ostraciser
est désigné alors vous avez vous avez
été rapporteur de la mission
parlementaire sur les produits
phytopharmaceutiques didier martin et
justement on va on va donner la parole à
fabrice belin parce que c'est notre
agriculteur il est céréalier pas très
très loin d'ici ils écoutent ce débat
autour de la chasse depuis un moment
fabrice jonah est ce que ça vous parle
ce débat entre chasseurs et écologistes
est ce que vous qui êtes au contact de
la nature tous les jours alors on verra
comment dans un instant c'est un débat
qui vous parle ou est ce que vous dites
c'est à côté de moi mais c'est pas la
même chose que moi
tout d'abord déjà merci de préciser que
nous on est au contact de la nature tous
les jours - moi je suis assez stupéfait
des fois par ses discours de l'écologie
sur une tribune moi je suis agriculteur
tous les jours on est en contact avec la
nature et on va dire tous les jours on
est obligé de faire des compromis avec
c'est à dire que quand on fait un métier
comme le mien on sait pertinemment qu'on
a un impact sur l'environnement et on
essaye d'avoir un impact le moins
négatifs possibles les mois je pense que
les cônes l'écologie l'économie puisque
c'est le matin des lapsus c'est fait de
compromis c'est à dire que on peut
jamais choisir de faire un acte qui est
blanc ou noir tu à dire qu'à chaque fois
il faut faire des choix et et ce
compromis là l'agriculture l'a toujours
fait on a toujours répondu l'agriculture
depuis 60 ans a répondu à la demande de
la société
c'est pas nous qui avons choisi après la
guerre de dire il faut produire
on sortait d'une une période où tout le
monde ne mange pas à sa faim
on pourra dire que c'est peut-être
encore le cas aujourd'hui mais sauf qu
on a quand même su répondre à un enjeu
majeur après la guerre de dié il faut
produire et jacques vous êtes un jeune
agriculteur est ce que c'est fini cette
période là bien sûr que c'est fini ce
fait ça fait au moins quinze ans que
l'agriculture
a pris conscience qu'il fallait qu'on a
un impact positif sur l'environnement
on travaille la fnsea aujourd'hui à
proposer un contrat de solution est
convaincue que l'écologie on la fera pas
tout seul
ce sera avec l'ensemble des acteurs du
terrain avec les scientifiques on oublie
aujourd'hui assez souvent en france
quand on parle d'écologie on laisse
parler des gens qui défendent des idées
aux il faudrait qu'on laisse parler un
tout petit peu plus des scientifiques
qui pourrait nous amener des solutions
et essayer d'avancer
moi moi c'est comme les chasseurs vous
n'êtes pas victimes d'une certaine image
qui peut-être date un peu
vous le disiez mais qui qui hélas cette
agriculture productiviste moi moi je
suis pas sûr il ya cette image qui peut
être amenée par certains vecteurs de
palme le grand public autour de moi les
gens qui sont produits à mon
exploitation
quand on a un problème on est capable
d'en parler ensemble d'expliquer notre
métier est pourquoi on fait les choses
et les gens quand on leur explique
comment on fait les efforts qu'on essaye
de faire en leur expliquant qu on est
sur un milieu naturel
les solutions qu'on imagine aujourd'hui
il va falloir un temps pour qu'ils aient
une réponse donc c'est pas on n'est pas
dans un milieu fermé un vase clos ont
modifié un facteur et les choses
changent tout de suite ça prendra du
temps et il faut encore une fois moi je
le répète le mot c'est le compromis
je pense que s'il ya un échec de la
l'écologie politique c'est parce qu'on
avait des gens qui croyaient qu'on
pouvait prendre les grandes décisions
sans mettre tout le monde d'accord
allait avancer l'écologie sur wiiware
améliorer les choses on le fera ensemble
alors on va on va faire évidemment
réagir ceux qui sont autour de nous mais
d'abord elsa il ya des gens avec vous
qui nous écoutent patiemment depuis un
petit moment déjà
oui qui vous écoute et puis je peux vous
dire qu'ici aussi on discute ici aussi
je viens de voir pipeau pipeau
donc on a beaucoup de choses à dire
fabien vous êtes venu vous êtes venu me
voir tout à l'heure parce que vous
souhaitiez vous réagir à ce que vous
avez entendu tout à fait par rapport à
ce que des messieurs s'est plaint un
clic il y en a qui aiment bien parler de
chiffres
et le bal perdu pour commencer la balle
perdue il faut en parler à la jeune
fille de 10 ans la semaine dernière
le jour de l'ouverture de la chasse à
côté de limoges qui a pris une balle
perdue ou pas voilà faudra lui en parler
ensuite parlant de chiffres 1 million à
peine plus d'un million de chasseurs en
france 65 millions d'habitants
voilà la forêt est privatisée ni pu les
moyens pour une minorité
c'est quelque chose d'hallucinant à tel
point que les partis ou d'une
association je précise qu'ils défendent
l'environnement voilà l'association
comme active en bourgogne franche comté
l'année dernière le maire dit sur tille
qu'at-il fait il a tout simplement
rédiger un arrêté municipal pour
interdire la forêt à tout public qui
n'est pas chasseur est ce que ça c'est
normal c'est quelque chose d'aberrant
voilà votre position sur la cause
animale
votre question est si vague un animal
est un être vivant
sens-tu ans donc je vais bien qu'il
reste des choses moi la grande question
là où la première question que j'ai
envie de poser un chasseur c'est comment
il peut faire pour enlever la vie à un
être vivant
quand on voit tous les animaux empaillés
fille comment c'est possible d'enlever
la vie est un animal comme ça et après
bafa bien on va la poser cette question
parce que regarder on a un chasseur
juste à côté de vous comment vous faites
pour enlever la vie à un animal c'était
sa question
ah bah comment on fait pour enlever la
vienne animal c'est parce que on se
comporte en gestionnaires responsables
et que la loi en france
tran semaine la responsabilité de la
gestion du gibier depuis la fin des
années 60 depuis exactement la veine
l'avènement d'une mesure légale qui
s'appelle le plan chasse et qui rend le
chasseur responsable de la partie gibier
de la faune sauvage en lui disant vous
la gérez vous la prélever de façon
responsable et si vous ne le faites pas
de façon suffisant suffisante et bien
les dégâts qui seront occasionnés
notamment
au monde agricole et bien vous êtes en
charge de les indemniser à travers des
fonds qui sont prélevées auprès des
chasseurs eux-mêmes et de personne
d'autre
donc voilà c'est ce que vous avez
l'impression de faire vous abbas et
parce qu'on a l'impression de faire
c'est ce qu'on fait au quotidien puisque
ces chiffres et ces chiffres à blé que
et que le monde agricole en est
conscient et qu'on a on est en
permanence en relation avec eux pour
évaluer estimer exactement et payez donc
c'est des gars donc voilà effectivement
donner la vie ou donner la mort c'est un
acte lourd de conséquences
c'est pas quelque chose c'est pas un
plaisir sadique de notre part mais c'est
aussi une façon de se comporter par
rapport au monde animal
merci à vous messieurs on poursuit le
débat avec vous jean christophe très
intéressant effectivement alors on est
revenu un petit peu sur la chasse mais
on a vu fabrice jeannet qui avaient des
liens entre entre les chasseurs et les
agriculteurs et que vous partagez avec
aussi ceux qui viennent se promener
parce qu'on va pas les oublier un ceux
qui viennent profiter de la nature vous
partager un même territoire vous avez ce
sentiment là vous oui moi j'ai le
sentiment qu'on partage un territoire
alors sacrée entre nous des fois des
discussions parce que toujours d'accord
non plus effectivement quand on l'a
appelée à l'agriculture c'est quand même
une sur ses économies et les
agriculteurs vivent de leur métier
la chasse ne faut pas non plus se cacher
les choses pour beaucoup de territoires
ruraux c'est aussi une économie
donc à partir du monde et fois deux
acteurs ont des des enjeux qui sont
différents effectivement ça peut créer
des tensions
nous on est en discussion avec la
fédération des chasseurs
les discussions des fois son âtre au
défend nos intérêts y défendre leur
position mais bien au delà de ça on est
convaincu que forcément on a des envies
ensemble parce que encore une fois on
essaye de résoudre des problèmes
en excluant les gens qui sont sur les
territoires et l'agriculture moi moi je
vais pas parler spécialement de la
chasse puisque je suis pas spécialiste
mais l'agriculture
on a compris que la société attend autre
chose de nous aujourd'hui ça fait je
pense au moins une quinzaine d'années
conques ont fait de gros efforts pour
changer nos pratiques d'où le débat de
ces derniers
jour de ces derniers mois sur la
question de l'utilisation des pesticides
et particulièrement du fameux glyphosate
dont on a beaucoup parlé je vais vous
redonner la parole fabrice jeannet
j'aimerais qu'on aille sur ce terrain là
avec olivier muller d'europe écologie
les verts c'est un débat qui est
évidemment transcende les partis on l'a
bien vu on le verra aussi avec didier
martin mais qui a aussi posé beaucoup de
problèmes à l'intérieur du gouvernement
entre le ministre de l'agriculture et le
ministre de l'environnement oui tout à
fait c'est face et surtout que le
ministre de l'environnement et était
complètement isolé dans un gouvernement
qui n'avait aucun aucun intérêt qui n'a
toujours aucun intérêt pour pour
l'écologie le gouvernement je vais
laisser par les gouvernements est encore
l'interdiction du glyphosate sa mission
c'est quand quoi mais où par contre vous
avez parlé de éventuellement vos
discussions âpres avec les agriculteurs
mais avait été chaque avec les chasseurs
pardon c'est précisément le problème
qu'on a aujourd'hui dans votre campagne
je pense on a on a un problème de
partage de l'espace entre des
agriculteurs qui qui par leurs pratiques
mettent en danger la biodiversité
on a des chasseurs qui essayent de qui
aimerait continuer à chasser gay c'est
de protéger la biodiversité vous vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure à monsieur
séduire et par exemple un terrain
d'entente
en ce moment tous les trois ou tous les
cinq d'ailleurs vous vous questionnez
comme nous sur les questions de
sécheresse je sais que ça pose des
problèmes aux chasseurs je sais que ça
pose des problèmes aux agriculteurs je
sais que ça questionne beaucoup les
écologistes alors aujourd'hui on est
enfin tout de suite on aimerait qu'ils
ne peuvent pas là tout de suite la
falaise ce serait bien mais les nappes
90 heures oui tout de suite
je leur demanderai d'attendre encore
quelques minutes que minutes pour pas
qu'on soit remplie vous voyez une petite
intervention de ma part encore sous
forme de boutade un chasseur ça ne
craint pas l'humidité par tous les temps
hiver on peut aller les pieds dans la
neige sous la pluie on sera au pied d'un
arbre vivre notre passion ça ne nous
gêne pas tandis que le vrai écologistes
lui reste devant sa télévision
chauffez éventuellement par un chauffage
central ou électrique énergie nucléaire
ça lui pose pas de problème donc il peut
pleuvoir tout de suite ça me pose encore
ben moi je me répondent le vrai le vrai
en un mot il ay là parce que si on est
dans les caricatures leur écologistes il
a savez
là il a hélas son manteau jaune à son
ciré jaune merci vous inquiétez pas il
est aussi sur le terrain alors ils sont
à ma réaction au bond et martin les
propos de monsieur je n'en sais ça qui a
dit que les citoyens avaient compris
qu'ils voulaient une nouvelle
agriculture et moi je suis vraiment
d'accord avec ça on voit très bien que
la l'agriculture actuelle fait fait des
ravages notamment sur l'environnement
le productivisme comme vous l'avez dit
vous avez posé la question tout à
l'heure fait des ravages et
qu'effectivement il faut vraiment passer
aujourd'hui à une agriculture paysanne
bio et c'est encore une fois pas grand
chose n'est fait en ce sens par la
majorité en marche concernant la
question des glyphosate la majorité se
tarit de dire oui mais grâce à nous
c'est sur la table c'est pour trois ans
il avait la possibilité de l'interdire
dès maintenant et deux peut-être
investir trouver des solutions
alternatives
parce que on va vous répondre je vous
coupe boris obama et j'aimerais entendre
original si on interdisait demain on
fait comment fabrice jonah est ce que
vous pourrez avoir une interdiction dans
la loi demain avec lui
votre travail de céréaliers par exemple
il faut il faut prendre un peu de
hauteur
quand on parle du glyphosate il faut il
faut quand même reprendre un peu le
contexte mondial
l'agriculture française effectivement
utilise du glyphosate
il faut savoir que notre utilisation du
glyphosate est modéré par rapport à tous
les autres pays les grands pays
exportateurs
il faut sinon mais pourquoi tous
d'accord respecter respecter
laissez moi parler ouais j'aurais je
pourrais comprendre que vous réagissiez
que vous soyez pas d'accord aujourd'hui
en france on utilise le glyphosate
uniquement entre deux cultures
on ne met jamais sur une culture avant
de le récolter ma question c'est est-ce
que vous pourriez vous en passer
aujourd'hui on n'est pas capable de s'en
passer et notamment moi il fait il ya
vous savez en agriculture contrairement
à ce qu'on peut croire il ya une forme
d'agriculture il ya plusieurs formes
d'agriculture l'agriculture biologique
il ya l'agriculture conventionnelle il
ya de la production de masse mais il ya
aussi de la production on va dire très
localisés et aujourd'hui l'agriculture
on va dire qui pourrait être la plus
moderne
si je prends l'exemple de l'agriculture
de conservation c'est à dire que on
travaille plus du tout les seuls le but
c'est d'essayer de d'avoir une
interaction sur le relâchement du
carbone cette agriculture là qui est à
la pointe
on va dire de l'environnement a besoin
du glyphosate parce qu'aujourd'hui ne
plus travailler les sols c'est peut-être
un peu contradictoire et ben c'est
vraiment plus que contradictoires donc
moi encore une fois se passer du
glyphosate
on est agriculteur tous les jours on
enlève des défis si demain la société
nous dit il faut rester petit livre vous
êtes on s'en passera la condition la
condition qu'on demande c'est que les
produits qui sont reportés en france qui
viennent d'agriculture du canada qui
viennent du brésil respecte les mêmes
amis renvoi du glyphosate bien sûr après
à faire tous les efforts qu'il faut mais
sachez que font rentrer dans le contexte
le milieu naturel on n'a pas une
réaction immédiate
exactement
on va aller voir elle a besoin parce que
ça réagit aussi de votre côté elsa il ya
des gens qui font des choix différents
parfois oui forcément vous l'imaginez la
question du glyphosate ici a fait réagir
est ce que vous pensez vous que glee
faisable de façon modérée c'est possible
bonjour donc moi c'est jean-marc je suis
membre de l'association qui s'appelle
nature et progrès
et donc ce nature progrès c'est une
association qui à 53 ans donc c'est les
pionniers historique de la bio et donc
nature et progrès étaient à la base de
la création mondiale des cahiers des
charges de la bio qui ont été reprises
après par le bio français et donc le
gros problème qu'on a en france c'est la
formation des agriculteurs
donc la bio ça existe depuis 50 60 ans
ayant encore des gens qui n'ont pas
appris à cultiver la terre sainement je
dirais donc c'est eu les premières
victimes qui s'empoisonne les fabricants
de produits 100 personnes et on a
vraiment besoin de changer tout ça donc
il ya l'appel des coquelicots qui est
qu'on peut se passer des choses est au
quotidien mais bien sûr il ya plein y
compris en côte d'or il ya des
agriculteurs bio ou des pas certifiés
qui se passe de tous les produits
chimiques et l'appel des coquelicots
donc ses dires il suffit pas d'interdire
un produit pour le remplacer par dix
encore plus toxique il faut vraiment
sortir de l'ère des puisque c'est
compatible avec le rendement bien sûr
c'est compatible avec le rendement avec
aussi l' équilibre économique
donc on dépense moins de frais de
produits alors phytosanitaires je
supporte pas le moche vraiment
allergique au portugal on appeler les
choses par leur nom on appelle ça un
agrotoxiques c'est des produits qui
tuent les gens
donc on demande aussi l'arrêt de la de
l'épandage à côté dans un premier temps
à côté des écoles des maisons etc
et puis on a un autre problème aussi
c'est la réglementation française avec
les ogm les ogm c'est des plantes qui
sont faites pour encaisser les
pesticides et donc on a une victoire
juridique tout récemment auprès de la
cour de justice de l'union européenne et
ont donc on demande le gouvernement et
donc j'interpelle monsieur d'idées
martin pour qu'ils fassent pression
là-dessus pour que le gouvernement
interdise les semis d'école sa variété
rendu tolérantes aux ogm parce
qu'actuellement n'assure marché de
l'huile de colza de l'it de tournesol
qui ogm en france
plus les importations pour nourrir le
bétail dans tous les ports français
voilà une question pour didier martin
alors justement on va faire répondre
didier martin et fabrice jona parce
qu'il a aussi des choses à dire sur
l'agriculture biologique et puis tout ce
cri qui sont autour de nous didier
martin alors sur cette question du colza
et des ogm peut-être d'abord qui on
revient très vite sur la question du
glyphosate la question des ogm elle est
pas nouvelle elle se pose pareil pour le
soja par exemple avec des importations
massives
de pays hors de notre continent
et si on mettait en place un plan
protéines animales rapidement si on ne
met pas nos agriculteurs à être
concurrentielles sur ce secteur là mais
on est condamné pour élever nos animaux
à importer massivement des sojas qui
sont effectivement roundup résistant et
ça c'est pas tolérable il faut bien
savoir que la conversion agro écologique
c'est quelque chose qui se fait
progressivement
moi j'entends qu'un la prise de
conscience elle est à peu près
généralisée monsieur eddy l'agriculture
bio ça existe depuis 50 60 ans oui il y
en a qui font la résistance bien résisté
ils n'ont mais il y à 6,5 pour cent de
la surface agricole utile qui est
consacrée au bio nous le gouvernement
actuel s'est fixé l'objectif de plus que
doubler cette surface agricole dans les
cinq ans qui viennent
voilà alors je pourrai répondre par
ailleurs sur la qualité de l'air sur la
qualité de l'eau sur la sortie de la
décision sur notre dame des landes sur
la fin des des centrales des centrales à
charbon sur la fermeture programmée de
fait celle d'un oui donc je ne vais pas
me laisser vous à piéger par le
déguisement qu'on veut faire porter
alors enfin oui enfin visionner un mot
parce que il a été directement n'ont pas
mis en cause mais enfin vous étiez
concernés en tous les cas au premier
chef
avoir au moins un droit de réponse faut
rappeler un préalable il n'y a pas de
culture d' ogm en france
il n'y a pas de culture des ogm en
france
donc ça c'est lampard est notoire
d'importation ah bah oui hélas nous
c'est bien notre problème c'est qu'on
nous met en concurrence avec des zones
de production qui n'utilisent pas du
tout les mêmes produits que nous et qui
ont du coup pas les mêmes coûts de
production donc ça c'est le premier
point il n'y a pas de culture de gm en
france
le deuxième point il n'y a pas
d'opposition entre l'agriculture
conventionnelle et le bio aujourd'hui on
le sent bien il ya des consommateurs qui
ont une demande en produits biologiques
aujourd'hui la griffe l'agriculture
française n'arrive pas à produire toute
cette demande
donc on a des cahiers des charges qui
sont faits on va dire ailleurs dans le
monde qui n'ont pas du tout les mêmes
cahiers des charges que nos cahiers des
charges bio et on importe on voyait jus
frais bio importés je pense qu'avec les
mêmes critères quoi il faut raisonner
offre et demande
le bio s'il ya une demande de bio
les filières vont se mettre en place il
faut surtout produire en fonction de la
demande des consommateurs il n'y a pas
une demande des consommateurs 100% bio
aujourd'hui faut bien être conscient
maurice mann et puis très important ce
que je viens d'entendre c'est que d'un
côté monsieur martin nous dit qu'il faut
aider le bio le diversifier alors qu'on
les agriculteurs les dernières
statistiques ne disent que les fonds
pour les gens qui veulent sans organiser
dans ce type de production
il n'y a pas de fonds qui sont mis en
place donc ils ne peuvent pas le faire
et le second point c'est qu'on nous dit
qu'il faut aussi basse si vous voulez
mais c'est un fait et le second point
qui est très intéressant c'est qu'on
nous dit on cultive pas nos gênes
extérieures on importe des choses on
veut des traités comme le ceta etc qui
sont catastrophiques pour
l'environnement pour la qualité des
aliments importés etc
vous défendez sur pour l'exportation des
produits français
dako d'accord mais pour l'importation
des produits français ne sont peut-être
pas bon et on entendra peut-être
monsieur parler à ce niveau là donc le
et en même temps qu on entend sans cesse
d'en bas mais compliqué quand même et on
le voit bien avec la démission de
nicolas hulot à amo olivier muller aussi
sur les conditions d'élevage parce que
c'est un aspect l'agriculture qu'on n'a
pas encore abordé mon pour l'exportation
des produits français mais si c'est pour
pourrir nos sols pour pouvoir mieux
exporté je vois pas non plus quel est
l'intérêt ce que l'intérêt c'est quand
même de bien manger
on a un train de perdre de vue
l'essentiel du sujet c'était le but de
la loi convient d'adopter
oui bah c'est un petit peu un petit peu
raté notamment en allusion à une culture
alimentation au niveau du lycée
c'est un petit peu raté parce
qu'effectivement sur scène et durable
c'était le but de la loi qui vient
d'être adoptée dont on a toujours le
diffuseur auteur
le glyphosate dispose pas le glyphosate
utilise en france il se pose pas sur la
qualité de la nourriture on ne retrouve
pas de trace de glyphosate sur les
aliments produits on peut en aurait pas
de trace de péter j écoutais attendez
laissez moi dans les discours un peu on
peut trouver du glyphosate et on peut
imaginer que le glyphosate nuisent à la
qualité des sols à la qualité de l'eau
sans on peut on peut le dire il est
estimé par mais c'est quoi la différence
entre l'agriculture bio et l agrément
une pratique et s'il n'y a pas de
différence sur les aliments qu'on mange
il sur les aliments qu'on mange et il
faut quand même se rendre compte d'une
chose les aliments produits en france
sont partis font partie des plus sûrs au
monde c'est à dire que on retrouve
je ne vous dis pas qu'on arrête mais je
vous dis qui vous dit qu'il ya déjà eu
des efforts c'est ça qui le gère je
remets pas en cause le travail des
agriculteurs métier très difficile et et
en plus ils sont réelles souffrances
aujourd'hui mais je pense qu'ils sont
sûrs d'eux ils sont en plus c'est les
premières victimes des produits qu'ils
mettent dans leurs champs mais ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'ils sont les
premières victimes
aussi de la façon dont ils produisent le
la nourriture aujourd'hui l'agriculteur
biologique on a vu ça marche très très
bien
c'est un modèle économique qui est
solide simplement il faut renforcer les
filières on peut pas effectivement
massifier le biologique du jour au
lendemain vous dites que vous faites des
efforts pour pour les pesticides on a
une augmentation alors que vous avez
pris en conscience vous avez mis du
temps avant de prendre conscience que
c'était effectivement un problème de
santé publique
si c'est un problème de santé publique
le les pesticides me dites pas qu'on
n'en trouve pas dans notre alimentation
demain les faire votre examen de deux de
vos cheveux vous allez voir que vous
avez des pesticides attend les romans on
va écouter une agricultrice qui est avec
elle a besoin et qui souhaitent réagir à
ce débat et justement va se diriger vers
justine et les agricultrices en franche
comté en haute saône
justin quand vous entendez parler là du
bio du glyphosate vous c'est une
réflexion que vous avez en tant que je
n'ai que mes alors justin donc je
secrétaire général des jeunes
agriculteurs bloquent en franche-comté
agricultrice donc oui moi quand
j'entends bio ben si on veut du bio
allons-y mais alors il faut nous payer
il faut plus de bio importé puits
conventionnels importés pas de souci je
suis pas sûr que tous les mânes minaj
soit capable de payer du bio et il faut
arrêter que ce glyphosate quoi
le glyphosate fabrice l'a dit tout à
l'heure pour tous qui est maintien des
sols c'est important quoi l'érosion
aussi quoi on parle de plus en plus
d'inondations
si si on fait plus des techniques
culturales simplifiées ou n'utilise pas
le labour et qui permet de maintenir le
seul déjà quand tu auras des inondations
déjà y aura moines boukir adore les
maisons parce que ça c'est une
catastrophique et en plus voilà le
glyphosate c'est on en a besoin quoi
c'est impossible pour vous de ne pas
l'utiliser au quotidien
c'est possible mais pas dans toutes les
cultures mois chez moi je peux me le
permettre parce que j'ai aussi envie de
passer en bio c'est une volonté donc
vraiment c'est important on a une
volonté de passer en bio volonté de
faire mieux
ça c'est sûr chez moi c'est possible
parce que j'ai 88 80 % d'herbe mais
quand on est en céréales 100% c'est réel
c'est quand même compliqué quoi vous
avez une question aux élus s'ils veulent
qu'on fasse du bio comment voilà comment
comment s'y prendre voilà voilà la
question est posée
didier martin vous êtes député vous
d'ailleurs il ya quelques jours à la
semaine dernière à vous avez voté pour
l'interdiction du glyphosate alors même
que votre groupe n'est pas exactement
sur cette position
l'agricultrice convient d'entendre elle
dit on peut pas se passer du glyphosate
et en même temps on voit qu'elle aspire
à passer au bio c'est presque
contradictoire dans sa tête c'est pas
simple comment on fait pour les aider
vous savez moi je suis allé un peu sur
le terrain aussi en côte d'or
technique et l'agriculture de
conservation des sols qui qui est
intéressante qui aujourd'hui encore
besoin de un peu de glyphosate 0 5 1
litres par hectare ce qui est quand même
très peu et effectivement cette
conservation des sols
elle permet la fixation du carbone dans
les sols respecte la microbiologie des
sols donc rejeté le lit faisant en bloc
dès maintenant alors qu'il ya des gens
qui travaillent depuis des années sur
l'amélioration de leurs pratiques c'est
intéressant
oui j'ai voté pour l'inscription de
l'interdiction du rif osa dans la loi
parce qu'aujourd'hui l'opinion le
demande
donc il faut envoyer un signal fort on a
quand même vu un été avec la
condamnation de monsanto à cause de
johnson de wayne malades intoxiqué
empoisonné par le before that
massivement on a voté aussi le principe
de mettre en place un fonds
d'indemnisation des victimes du
glyphosate en france ça ne s'était
jamais fait et puis dernier point sur la
conversion des agriculteurs au bio dans
le cadre du plan ecophyto plus on va
avoir des primes de conversion
intéressante importante pour atteindre
cet objectif que nous avons fixés avec
les professionnels parce que nous on va
pas faire la guerre aux conversions sans
les agriculteurs alors olivier muller on
a on a parlé depuis le début de cette
émission de ces questions d'écologie
aujourd'hui on voit bien cette semaine
pas plus tard que cette semaine le
ministre de l'environnement et le
ministre de l'agriculture aller ensemble
sur le terrain c'était pas vraiment
nicolas hulot stéphane travert tu aurais
pu faire alors il a fait un déplacement
en hélicoptère aussi c'est vrai mais est
ce qu'il ne faut pas aller jusque là
c'est à dire voir comment on peut
concilier ces différents domaines et
essayer de travailler en ce sens avait
là la réflexion à voir c'est que
notamment pour la question
environnementale en fait on n'a plus le
temps c'est une nouvelle
je pense révolution qu'il faut faire
aujourd'hui lequel fabrice ya là il vous
dit je parle cinq minutes
non mais peut-être mais ce qu'il faut
surtout faire pour monsieur jonas et lui
donner les moyens de pouvoir le faire et
comme on le voit des gens nous disent
que des alternatives existent ont il ya
quelques années par rapport à la halle à
l'amiante notamment tout le monde savait
que c'était dangereux personnes
le vin tout le monde le disait et ses
amis des années avant qu'on interdise et
finalement aujourd'hui personne ne remet
en cause cette question là et ça sera de
même dans glyphosate je suis persuadé
que dans trois quatre cinq ans se dira
finalement pourquoi est ce qu'on ne l'a
pas fait plus tôt
et c'est notre responsabilité il faut
suivre aussi un petit peu l'actualité on
a aussi entendu que l'agriculture bio
c'était cher pour les ménages parce que
on va parler que d'eux mais tout à côté
de l'info il faut que c'est aussi dans
la démocratisant qu'on la rendra de plus
en plus accessible nous ont proposés
dans les cantines bio pour les enfants
nous l'avons voté 50% du bio dans les
cantines scolaires dans les cinq ans qui
viennent
c'est l'objectif que l'on voté moi j'ai
envie d'entendre le chasseur parce que
la biodiversité le respect de
l'environnement et où vous ça vous
concerne aussi est ce que ce débat sur
les pesticides sur l'agriculture
raisonnée sur l'agriculture biologique
vous vous sentez concerné est partie
prenante bien sûr qu'on se sent concerné
d'ailleurs on s'est exprimé au niveau
national ça nous a d'ailleurs valu
quelques désaccords au niveau national
avec madame lambert présidente de la
fnsea
parce qu'on s'est exprimé pour la petite
faune notamment la disparition de tous
les insectes quand on a une agriculture
de production si je puis dire
forcément c'est au détriment de toute la
de tous les insectes et de la
disparition donc de la petite faune la
perdrix notamment donc ça c'est un sujet
qu'on est amené à travailler ensemble
comme la gestion des populations de
grands gibiers parce que je reviens un
peu à la ch une et oui forcément mais on
a des vrais on a des vrais échanges
mercredi prochain nous recevons à paris
la fnca et tout le staff justement pour
échanger la semaine dernière la fdsea du
doubs département du doubs a signé une
convention avec la fédération des
chasseurs du doubs pour travailler
ensemble sur tous ces sujets
pour les paquets gibier ingèrent des
pesticides je voulais le nouveau de la
question plus forcément s'il a gardé
intacte ici de sa sera pas bon pour pour
eux et pour nous également donc bien
évidemment tout le monde est d'accord
sur ce point alors il nous reste 5
minutes d'émission je sais que ça passe
très vite même si on a souhaité
consacrer une heure à ce débat on va
donner la parole à ceux qui sont autour
de vous est là pour des réactions assez
courte et peut-être plusieurs oui oui
effectivement toujours beaucoup de
réactions ici je vais me tourner vers un
élu qui m'a interpellé qui m'a dit moi
j'ai envie de dire quelque chose et
notamment sur la vous ce qui vous fait
réagir c'est la cantine et le bio à la
cantine
oui patrick châteaux je suis adjoint au
maire de dijon
j'ai notamment en charge le dossier de
la part des produits bio dans la
restauration municipale alors des
chiffres tout simplement à la ville de
dijon
en quatre ans nous avons monté le taux
de bio de 11 % à 30 %
mais en baissant le coût matière ce que
j'ai entendu tout à l'heure à oui mais
le bio ça coûte plus cher etc je pense
que ce que nous avons réalisé à dijon
c'est à dire réorienter aussi
l'alimentation le les repas les menus et
puis travailler sur le gaspillage
alimentaire
donc c'est comme ça que nous avons
réussi à progresser autre sujet je
reviens un peu à la chasse mais quand je
vois le en face de moi la fiche un monde
sans chasse c'est la nature qui se meurt
je pense qu'il faudrait réinventer la
place de l'humanité dans la biodiversité
je pense que on n'a pas encore
complètement compris que l'humanité
appartient la biodiversité et que quand
j'entends les scientifiques nous alerte
en disant on est dans la sixième
extinction
je pense qu'il faut vraiment bougé faut
vraiment agir et que le facteur temps
c'est quelque chose d'essentiel dans
tout ce que nous entreprenons les
agriculteurs les chasseurs les
écologistes et l'écologie politique
n'est pas morte et la preuve en est
c'est qu'en fait maintenant tout le
monde en parle donc on a bien fait notre
travail
on a alerté et j'aimerais bien qu'on
respecte ça merci la part du bio qu'est
ce que vous en pensez à s'est passé
c'est cher c'est pas cher vous quel est
votre avis là-dessus la part du bio
j'entends ce que dit patrick châteaux je
pense que c'est complètement réalisable
d'augmenter le bio dans les cantines il
suffit de réorienter et de manger
autrement
je pense que pour un ménage
classique normal moi manger mieux c'est
possible c'est pas forcément plus cher
donc je pense que voilà c'est une
question de choix à chacun a le choix de
ce qui veut manger et ce qu'ils
souhaitent manger ce qui veut manger
autant de viande est ce que réduire un
peu la part de viande et manger mieux
c'est vraiment choix donc voilà je pense
que chacun le choix de ce qui veut faire
et c'est pas c'est pas un anti
économique
merci beaucoup on n'a pas beaucoup
encore parler d'élevage et de condition
animale olivier muller mais quand on dit
manger de la viande quelle viande c'est
une question qui se pose aussi quelle
viande
enfin ça a été dit chacun évidemment est
libre de manger ce qu'il veut
concernant juste le le coût du du bio
c'est pas plus cher de bien manger
effectivement alors ça passe peut-être
par manger ça la ménagère ou aux
personnes qui font les courses dans le
foyer c'est pas forcément évidemment oui
m'enfin ça se voit pas au premier abord
je pense qu'on peut éviter de manger de
la merde excusez moi et puis
industrielle ce qu'il faut c'est
peut-être essayer cuisine et je pense
qu'il faut il faut il faut préparer les
aliments un petit peu plus et ne pas
faire confiance à l'industrie agrumes
agroalimentaire avec la fnsea vous avez
fait vous faites du volume vous faites
du peut-être du pas cher mais on peut je
pense manger mieux en essayant de
cuisine et un peu plus mon ça c'est mon
avis personnel tu voues par les
ménagères c'est très réducteur de dire à
la fnsea
aujourd'hui nous sommes convaincus il ya
plusieurs agriculture il ya plusieurs
demandes des consommateurs il ya des
consommateurs qui demandent encore des
produits pas chers et je pense qu'ils
sont aussi en droit de faire des choix
iliad et d'autres populations qui
demandent des de la nourriture plus
élaborés ou avec parce qu'il faut quand
même sortir que le bio ça sera forcément
vous l'avez dit moins de roulements et
il faudra un prix plus élevé payé aux
producteurs pour qu'ils continuent de
vivre est-ce qu'on a encore didier
martin le choix d'avoir plusieurs
agriculture qui cohabitent ou est-ce que
c'est bientôt terminé et nous reste une
minute démission je vous dis oui ce sens
sans problème l'agriculture périurbaine
les circuits courts
manger local c'est tout à fait possible
les légumes riz de proximité c'est
possible à mettre en place
d'autres évolutions à mettre à mettre
dans les esprits et je salue les
politiques qui effectivement mettre du
bio dans les cantines scolaires
parce que ça commence par là l'éducation
et ben oui et puis c'est offrir à des
publics je suis désolé les plus démunis
ne mettent pas leurs enfants à la
cantine
donc il ya un problème d'accès à la
cantine et on peut offrir à cette
occasion que ce soit le petit déjeuner
en zone prioritaire qu'on veut mettre en
place après le dédoublement des classes
en zone prioritaire pour le cp et le ce1
à une bonne alimentation une bonne
éducation c'est fondamental alors qui
sont les nouveaux écologistes est ce que
autour la de la table déjà vous vous
sentez tous écolos on a bientôt on
arrive au terme de l'émission
maurice obama avance que c'est la sphère
de tous et qui a pas de
on n'est pas là pour distribuer des
permis de d'écologie ou pas j'entendais
juste le monsieur par les agriculteurs
les adducteurs ces gamines une
population qui en souffrance c'est quand
même une population où un agriculteur se
suicident qu'on en parle souvent tous
les deux jours c'est quand même on peut
pas fermer les yeux là dessus on peut
appeler les électeurs et qui souffrent
il faut vraiment changer de système
merci à tous d'avoir participé à cette
émission d'avoir accepté de débattre en
direct ce matin merci à ceux qui sont
juste à côté de nous avec elle a besoin
d'avoir participé à ce premier débat
citoyen ils n'étaient pas tous habitués
à parler ensemble mais on a ouvert le
débat en tous les cas dans un instant le
point sur l'actualité régionale suivi de
la suite de dimanche en politique suit
national avec francis letellier qui
reçoit le mathématicien et député lrm
cédric villani bon dimanche à tous et
merci